Oh Mohammed hasn't seen her two sons for
five years both were policemen and ISIL
fighters took them away when Mosul was
seized in 2014 as she told her story
more mothers gathered most of the men in
the wadi haggard neighborhood of mosul
worked for Iraq security forces before
ISIL took control they killed some men
and imprisoned others when the Iraqi
army regained control of Mosul two years
ago the prisoners in ISIL jails were
taken away along with their captors Omar
had only found out about her missing
sons when a policeman posted a photo of
them with ISIL prisoners you might say
matter to be a mom or my dad about dad
the last news I heard about them is that
they might be in a prison somewhere in
Baghdad my son served for the security
of this country why are they still being
detained whenever we go to the
authorities they tell us that our sons
don't exist in the system behind me is
the neighborhood where the last battles
against ISIL took place many families
say when they try to return to this area
and adjoining parts many men went
missing or they were arrested
arbitrarily since the fall of ISIL
thousands of men from Nineveh province
have been imprisoned by Iraqi security
forces carrying out counterterrorism
screening Human Rights Watch says it's
documented dozens of arbitrary arrests
and enforced disappearances family
members of people perceived to have ties
with ISIL are also rounded up routinely
they say what we need to see is the
government that starts taking seriously
its obligation to investigate abuse to
give answers to families about where
their loved ones are what happened to
them and where abuses are found to give
them compensation Human Rights Watch is
calling on Iraqi authorities to launch
these investigations and to give people
the answers that they deserve
both the Ministry of Defence and
Ministry of Justice in Baghdad didn't
respond to our requests for comment Shia
militias called popular mobilization
forces played a crucial role in driving
ISIL from Iraqi towns although they keep
a low profile the militias are the most
dominant force in Mosul many Sunni
Muslim residents who are scared to speak
on camera accused them of abuse and
forcing demographic change commanders of
the militias have repeatedly denied the
allegations human rights groups say the
fate of the men should be revealed
so far we have not received positive
answers from the federal government it's
a violation of the constitutional rights
because every person should be able to
live freely in the country that's not
the case with the missing people whose
families keep asking about them the
mothers of the missing are desperate for
news they say the government should
either let their missing sons come home
or hand over their bodies Osama bin
Javed al Jazeera Mosul